hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to phobia 1.50 this is
turning into such a great game I okay
that's how it's gonna be huh look at all
that we're call that textured Lilly
those textures on those walls look at
that lighting effects look at that
ambient occlusion
hi this place gave me the creeps how did
a single person achieve all this and for
what purpose actually I don't really
care all I want to get some fuel for me
to get out of this awful nightmare I
should search the place thoroughly I saw
the knife with me I wonder if it's
sturdy enough to pry this open oh if it
does boom there we go I did it alright
so do I want to go in there do I wanna
go in there maybe it's just a way to get
away from the monster after he comes
after me and I know he will
okay so I guess that's the only Avenue I
have creepy dark duct Gordon Freeman
would be proud of me sick over here
dead end okay alright nothing's gonna
pop out of me right right I'll get it
okay
nope just totally fine amazing duct work
for such a small lab dead-end Oh what am
i - isn't it's just oh oh that didn't
tell me at all
how's that even supposed to be remotely
helpful maybe that wasn't a dead end
over there maybe that was otherwise what
would be the point of all this right no
it was damn it what was the point of
that this is just to get away from the
monster really really really really huh
alright then that's what you say never
mind this was a waste of my time and
effort apologize everyone watching I
have failed you
so so what about that
was there another a I didn't check was
there something I meant not Debbie you
son of a [ __ ] stop doing that there boy
I didn't miss anything you doing oh I
tried it didn't work all right whatever
no whatever whatever whatever I tried it
you all saw I tried it didn't work
stupid stupid ad do it but face McGee
now we can get into here BAM [ __ ] and
now we're in the lab area note I don't
even know why I'm writing this I feel
the need to I have been locking doors
for some reason I feel like hiding
something I'm locking myself in the
basement behind them Oh oh you're not
the pretty lady I knew you were a bit
too ugly okay all along for decades it
was locked behind that metal door in the
basement and I let it out by switching
the power back on well way to go you
dick way to go [ __ ]
what what oh my god there's someone
there must be the test subject with a
horrible fate oh oh oh oh oh I can
barely see it but oh oh oh no oh let's
just leave that there
I didn't even see it at first that's
weird baby
oh so how did the original test subject
die but then this doctor douche somehow
survived maybe he killed off the
experiment whew
okay mister
ah this is almost too good to be true I
found I was looking for finally I just
have to get the hell out of here hey
look more fuel do I need it I should
probably take it but oh well just 9 ah
no run you dick how about I run Oh what
the hell what okay I'm out okay I'm up
[ __ ] I'm outie I'm Audi 5000 I'm out
of here I hope I go the right way
because if I haven't I'm going to be
royally boned I think it took a right
here Oh heat okay ah here we go alright
let's get the hell out what is it that
self-destruct sequence or something it
was just a little fall what won't open
must be said oh no no no no no no no no
no no oh no oh no oh no
here we go
come on banging Oh Maggie Oh Maggie boom
um oh no does it have to end like this
no okay so I can't go the wrong way cuz
apparently design of time
who's that closed - no - no loo some
bang boom bang zip stop do it about just
a pop hey I was right there I was right
there if I hadn't spent so long looking
at the douche on the ground I would have
made it oh oh that doesn't look good
the mixer seems forever oh this is a
fire escape
oh okay that does not look good that
looks like a conflagration I just barely
made it out of here now I've just got to
get the front door all the way that
thing blew up along with the lab I don't
think that's how this go okay close and
caused extensive damage I need to be
careful damage happened to this house ah
cramp cramp I guess I have to go the
long way around
oh oh oh well
oh it's ran blood but ago gonna ah yeah
can't go up there Kenan oh I can't okay
I got it I got it
come on you back it looked like the only
way to go how about you going all right
here we go back again or what doors or
buzzer boom baby all right blows an
extensive scale bleach happen we're
about over here
no okay Oh Oh No
thunk thunk Oh Rooney okay so it's gotta
be away after I go up go all over here
okay that was not obvious it's not
obvious okay so down here what Oh what
that doesn't help me how's that help me
that doesn't help me at all
what the hell what are you kidding me
what the hell how does that help me you
just let me in a circle you dick all
right let's try this again I guess
has to be some other way that it's
telling me to go I got to get over there
that's where I got again so wants me to
go over here then it doesn't want me to
go anywhere else
Oh over here I can barely see that oh
wait no yes maybe so over here here we
go
yeah Syd that's a stuff yeah buddy
all right all right all right our IRA oh
I can barely see I can't see all right
huh I'm okay whoa all righty then you
still a me yeah yeah ah I did it when I
got out of the house I ran as fast as I
could I didn't even stop for a second to
turn around and check if that thing went
after me
I didn't care about exhaustion I ran
till I was at my car again quickly after
that I got the car running and I was
back on the road again the more distance
I got from the house the more relieved I
felt I headed to the nearest town to
finally have some rest and to tell
everyone about this nightmare hidden in
the woods so another unlucky person
could stumble in it because I know I'll
never recover from the horrors I
experienced in there let me guess you
got a little drop in your eye oh no you
didn't okay alright then yeah that was
so much better than the original that
was infinitely infinitely better than
the original saying it's like just small
changes that does the real good to that
ah what what what so good what why I
loved it
what only a few bit of dickish nice but
that's all there was that was great I
loved it
Wow anyway alright it's only way that
has been phobia 1.5 whole bunch of
royalty-free stuff but seriously that
was awesome good job on the developer
good job on everyone who was part of it
yeah FPS creator engineers so weird you
know it looked fantastic for FPS creator
anyway
password to two three six I don't know
what that means
should I write that down that important
bad for two to three takes Oh what am i
doing writing it down and recording it
for the internet I don't need to write
it down dude do the readings awry
good job everything else nope that's it
alright
that is when phobia one-four-five hope
y'all enjoyed it I certainly did so
thank you all so much for watching
huh look the auntie's from more videos
that I've done as always I will see you
in the next video
I shall dispose of the revenger
feels kind of creepy all right come
Maria doctor
ha
what
I don't believe she's
oh girl will be 11 soon drop his man
yeah because